if you want to rebuild trust number one
everything's got to be on the table all
the secrets the second thing is if you
all choose to stay you choose to work
hard to rebuild the trust and I'm going
to add a third one you both have to be
very clear about what you need to help
rebuild Trust
that's it
those three things have to happen if you
want to rebuild trust and then it's just
going to take time there's going to be
ups and downs two steps forwards five
steps back he's going to have a glance
she's going to turn over her cell phone
he's going to put some money and a thing
he's going to give money at his local
it's just it's just it's a it's a thing
y'all gonna do together as you grow
together